er baggert sich immer näher heran an
dorf und hof bedrohliche aussichten für
norbert winzen
das ist die grundstücksgrenze hier und
da vorne ist schon die bagger das werden
so 3 400 meter noch sein
der ist extrem schnell näher gekommen
den letzten monaten nur noch drei jahre
dann soll sein zuhause sein land
verschwunden sein
im braunkohletagebau garzweiler 2038
steigt deutschland aus dem abbau von
braunkohle aus zu spät für die vinzenz
sie leben als großfamilie in einem
historischen gehört mit ihren tieren auf
8000 quadratmeter grund mein großvater
ist hier hingekommen als umsiedler vom
gleichen tage war übrigens vor über 60
jahren und da hat man im sack
hier ist das ein alter hof den kann zu
übernehmen ihr seid ihr sicher und jetzt
sind wir in der vierten generation schon
und müssen jetzt am gleichen tag aber
noch mal weg so wie es aussieht und das
ist natürlich schon ziemlich bitter das
wollen wir auch nicht
die vinzenz wollen sich wehren
doch die meisten ihrer nachbarn haben
aufgegeben auch wenn es ihnen schwer
fällt
ja so ja die heimat eben verlassen dass
er blöd eben weil so ein ort hier
bekommt man nicht mehr
wenn ihr also vorschreiben dass gegen
machen umsiedlung von traditionellen
jahrhundertealten bauerndörfern in halb
fertige neubausiedlungen mit 80 prozent
der dorfbewohner sei man sich
handelseinig sie würden entschädigt
informiert uns der braunkohle förderer
rwe viele leiden andere finden die
umsiedlung gut es gibt leute die auch
die verwandte haben oder die selber bei
rwe arbeiten die gibt es diese natürlich
davor die haben natürlich sorge um ihre
arbeitsplätze berechtigte sorge da ist
ja von meiner arbeit hat und es gibt
natürlich leute die auch erst mal ihre
vorteile daraus sehen ich meine die
finanzielle seite der umsiedlung die ist
ja nicht ungerecht und muss man schon
sagen
doch er vermisse sein altes dorf das sei
viel mehr als ein neubaugebiet die
obstgärten die wälder die quelle
deshalb unterstützt er die die bleiben
und kämpfen wollen wie marita driesen
meine eltern sagen halt immer sie
möchten nicht mehr erleben dass sie hier
wegmüssen also meine mutter sagt es
wirklich oft und fängt dann auch oft an
zu weinen
dass sie lieber sterben möchte als mit
ansehen zu müssen wie so ein kohle
bagger hier alles vernichtet und die
heimat weg ist deshalb haben sie und ihr
sohn die initiative alle dörfer bleiben
mitgegründet und stemmen sich gegen den
politischen beschluss das im rheinischen
braunkohlerevier noch sechs dörfer
abgebaggert werden
für mich ist das für eigene frage von
gerechtigkeit und ich finde es einfach
ungerecht dass menschen ihr zuhause
verlassen sollen für eine energieform
aus dem 19 jahrhundert
unterstützung erhält ihre initiative von
klimaaktivisten und so ist auf einmal
richtig was los auf den sonst eher
ruhigen und längst abgeschriebenen
dörfern am rande des tagebaus einige
hier befremdet der protest andere wie
die dresens sehen in der unterstützung
der klimaschutz bewegung eine chance die
bagger vielleicht doch noch zu stoppen
es gibt halt viel kraft weil man hat
schon manchmal so das gefühl wir hoffen
wir schaffen wir das und ich denke das
ist schon ein tolles zeichen
klimaaktivisten campieren seit wochen am
rande der dörfer ihre mahnwache ist
treffpunkt unterschiedlicher welten
gelernt das ist super wichtig ist aus
einer blase rauszukommen und irgendwie
offen zu sein für verschiedene
protestform verschiedene menschen die
unterschiedlich am gleichen strang
ziehen
für die dorfbewohner geht es um verlust
und zerstörung ihrer heimat sie
verstehen nicht warum sie noch ihre
häuser verlieren sollen braunkohle sei
nicht mehr mit dem pariser klimazielen
vereinbar
die maßnahme der umsiedlung
unverhältnismäßig
wir werden alle dörfer versuchen zu
halten und wir werden keinen deut
nachgeben wenn dann was mit literatur
kein berg was am nächsten an der kante
ist vielleicht dann zu knapp wird dann
wären wir die anderen erhalten
wir werden weitermachen an diesem
wochenende sind rund 1000 menschen
gekommen aus den dörfern und von weit
her
sie bilden eine menschenkette symbolisch
schutzwall für die dörfer die nach dem
tagebau weichen soll